il est assez étrange effectivement
j'accueille manson
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
vous parliez de drones tout à l'heure
j'étais même pas encore arrivé
bonsoir marilyn dont vous appelez
marilyn comme monroe et manson comme
charles manson
ça vous est venu comment cette idée
d'accoupler le nom d'un tueur en série
satanistes avec le prénom d'une icône
glamour de l'américain aaron hunt bea de
base sera peut être la meilleure
représentation possible de l'amérique
bonne surnom ses entés christ superstar
cela c'est bien qu'elles ont pensé le
cas mauvais un antéchrist superbe star
c'était le nom de garde meubles la
relève est assurée et marilyn manson est
une star donc du shock rock ce qu'on
peut appeler le shock rock alors dans la
tradition de badis toons avec sympathy
for de ville
ensuite il est black sabbath avec ozzy
osbourne alice cooper les sexpistols je
suis anarchiste je suis l'antéchrist
chantait johnny rotten alors on est très
contents de vous avoir ce soir parce que
vous êtes une star mondiale marilyn
votre prochain album s'appelle de golden
age of grotesque l'âge d'or du grotesque
et le premier single est déjà sorti et
il s'appelle moque chine
[Musique]
on y reviendra on y reviendra ça vous
plaît ça jane là mais jen vous rendez
compte quand même difficile se manie
sonne je sais rien email qui va nous
tomber beaucoup de gens règlent leur
téléviseur tout ça est normal que les
gens croient qu'ils regardent des
siennes à la fois une chaîne humaine
capello in china il émane pas du tout
c'est la même chaîne c'est france 2
vient donc sortie de votre album to man
album et puis l'autre raison de votre
présence ici c'est le succès mondial du
documentaire de michael moore qui
s'appelle bowling for columbine dont qui
a été évidemment pris mais un peu
partout aux césars aux oscars j'ai
consacré aux armes à feu aux usa alors
que l'on bein c'est une université du
michigan ou deux élèves avaient ouvert
le feu sur des camarades et on s'était
aperçu après que c'était des des fans de
vous voilà donc ces deux raisons de on
en parlera plus tard deux raisons nous
avoir ce soir mais on va commencer par
le début manson vous est né le 5 janvier
69 et votre vrai nom c'est brian hugh
warner
votre père était un ancien mécanicien
d'hélicoptère au vietnam je me trompe
jamais mois et 11 ans ce week-end monde
gérait une magasin de meubles et il est
seul moment d'intimité de votre père
avec vous c'était quand ils vous emmener
au stand de tir pour vous apprendre à
tirer ça c'était un vrai moment
d'intimité avec lui et puis aussi il
vous emmener au concert de kiss 1 à
robert gerber se très douces en bon père
abel justement un maquillage qui semmam
un concert dans cette tenue
mon papa était cool ça c'est votre papa
votre maman celle inverse elle était
très possessive traître est étouffante
comme ça et quand vous êtes petit marine
manson vous passez beaucoup de temps
chez vos grands-parents et vous
découvrez la sexualité dans la cave de
votre grand père voilà alors dans la
cave du grand-père à ça te plait ça
dégénère
ah la la alors dans la cave du grand
père de marie ligne avec quoi à maître
capello dans la cave du grand père de
manoeuvre il y avait des nazis y avait
des nuages gris féminine il y avait des
godemichets enduite vas-y les godemichés
et puis aussi des photos sophie la haye
est assez assez j'ai suivi c'est très
drôle de grand père avec un cheval
notamment quand j'étais gamin mon
grand-père ne pas rester un monstrueux
mais en grandissant se sont rendu compte
que mon grand-père était bon je suis
comme lui est pas si mal que ça va pas
que je n'aime pas trop les animaux pas
les faits la zoophilie
ce qui n'a pas tiré un cheval danseuse
j'étais là alors donc vous allez à
l'école et l'héritage christiane school
à et là évidemment on est mise à part
puisqu'il a aussi agi dans ce sens que
j'aime en faire un ami de capello merci
non plus donc voila vous allez dans
cette école donc on vous inculque des
valeurs fondées sur l'antéchrist et sur
l'apocalypse alors évidemment ça à tout
çà çà çà travail dans votre tête vous
essayez de vous adapter à l'école vous
essayez de vous adapter et un jour vous
leur apportez une photo c'est des nuages
dans le ciel qui représente un ange et
lui parce qu'il pense là un vous pensez
leur faire plaisir
c'était ma grand mère qui m'avait donné
ils m'ont dit que c'était un faux et
donc c'est la seule fois j'essaie de
m'intégrer vraiment dans ce but qu'on
m'a dit tout ça c'était du bidon mais
j'ai arrêté j'ai arrêté de croire ou des
c3 à ce qu'on raconte elle est alors au
lieu de vivre dans la peur d'avoir des
cauchemars les plats j'ai décidé de
devenir ce dont j'avais peur juste voilà
alors là c'est la révolte dès l'âge de
12 ans vous vous révoltez vous êtes
attiré par tout ce qui est interdit
vous êtes à l'époque vous est maigre
vous êtes couvert de boutons vous êtes
toujours tout seul en face vous avez une
adolescence ça c'est assez terrible en
moi je me sentais invisible et
transparence
c'était pas tous été rejetés j'étais
vraiment invisible on ne me voyait pas
et ça n'est qu'à travers la musique où
les créatures alors quand j'étais gamin
je me suis je serai artistes ou
écrivains je pensais que j'allais
chanter parce que je ne savais pas
chanter mais bon oui c'est comme ça que
j'ai trouvé ma propre voie je crée mon
monde et alors là en compagnie d'un
certain john kroell et son grand frère
au lycée vous commencé à vous intéresser
aux sciences occultes au couteau qu une
bonne nuit et zou au silence beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
pas grave blessure non non mais c'est
bien parce que comme ça ça cautionne et
c'est une très bonne idée là c'est le
service public service public vient donc
vous intéresser avec ce dénommé john
kroell aux sciences occultes aux
doctrines satanique 1 c'est l'époque où
nous visiter disneyland eux sous acide
des ca propose des bijoux rappelle un
peu cet épisode un peu surréaliste et là
vous faites de la scène donc chez nous
scandale évidemment vous masturber sur
scène un faux pénis qui éjacule un
liquide improbable vous jeter des n'a
pas eu recours à un accessoire dieu vous
vous jetez des poulets vivants public
mais c'est vrai que c'est le public qui
les égorge
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
noah
bachy
ouais
[Musique]
et maintenant mode chine
orlando